los científicos llevan años avisándonos
de los problemas que tiene nuestro
planeta Y de dónde han surgido los datos
demuestran que el cambio climático es el
fenómeno acelerado por la actividad
humana pero es también el Humano el que
a través de la ciencia y la innovación
tiene las soluciones la ciencia nos
permite adelantarnos y prevenir algunos
de los impactos de la crisis climática
es lo que pretende el sistema de
prevención temprana que lanzó la ONU
durante esta con 27 un plan que Antonio
Gutiérrez el secretario general quiere
implementar para proteger a toda la
población mundial antes de cinco años
proteger frente a huracanes sequías o
incendios sin embargo los últimos
informes avisan de que la capacidad de
adaptación de las comunidades es
limitada y que hay que trabajar más en
la mitigación es decir reducir las
emisiones que agravan esta crisis
climática más acción es lo que piden los
jóvenes que hoy tienen una ventana en la
cop en la agenda oficial de la cop27
algunos sienten que estamos entrando en
una nueva era de la lucha climática Me
parece que actualmente
en una era en la que el poder se está
redistribuyendo desde arriba hacia abajo
creo que ahora el poder es más circular
y viene desde el colectivo Entonces yo
creo que los jóvenes estamos
organizandonos en colectivos justamente
para promover la acción y para no
depender de líderes que usualmente se
sientan en negociaciones para iniciar
con el cambio desde nuestra cuenta desde
nuestros nichos desde nuestras propias
experiencias
América Latina está en el centro de los
peores efectos climáticos y Este joven
mexicano reprocha a su gobierno las
pocas acciones para proteger a los
mejores Defensores del planeta los
indígenas Me parece que en las
comunidades indígenas en México
usualmente tienen derechos humanos que
son violentados como el derecho a la
identidad me parece que es fuertísimo
que el gobierno mexicano no tome las
medidas suficientes para garantizar la
protección de sus derechos Me parece que
como colectivos y como sociedades
colectivas debemos de visualizar que
nosotros tenemos un control para
amplificar sus voces y para
pararnos en Solidaridad con con su lucha
una jornada en la que además hay varias
protestas planeadas para exigir mayor
financiación climática el tema central
de esta con 27